And she went to bring her ring in.
She found out was fake downtown to Trump.
Trump gave someone fake diamond cufflinks.
Who was that?
Somebody does all someone in business.
He gave him a pair of diamond cufflinks and he went and looked and they were
fucking CCS.
If that's the case,
if he did that to you,
that guy's ready to fuck you.
He's,
he's about to make something.
Go down.
Mueller,
Mueller got steam and right now fucking fake diamonds.
You don't respect me with to Trump.
Oh,
I don't respect Gil job is fake diamond cufflinks for years.
Oh my God.
He's hilarious.
Do they shrink his hands for those pictures on purpose?
No,
cause his hands aren't little.
Everybody was caused his hands little.
There's something he does with his hands that make them look little.
It's like he does a lot of stuff like this.
It's like he brings,
could just be little in proportion to his head,
which is gigantic and getting bigger.
Apparently poor.
He's,
he's going down now.
I mean when they raided his,
uh,
his attorney's offices,
here's the thing that to,
in order to get all that stuff pass through,
Republicans have to agree to that.
Yeah.
Like there's like in order to like actual Republicans and people that should be,
his supporters had to be a part of that.
I read that everyone that's signed,
it was an appointee of his administration.
He's in trouble.
They're reading your lawyers office.
You are so fucked.
And if it all goes down that he winds up getting in trouble.
Not even for Russia,
but for paying off a chick that he had sex with.
Imagine it's a porn chick that takes this whole thing down.
Listen man,
I need,
Oh,
Justin Martin,
Dale and apology.
He was saying that she's the Monica Lewinsky for this administration.
Oh,
come on.
No Way.
He's going to brush this off.
It's going to be nothing.
Nobody cares because everybody knows.
They know he did it.
So it's not,
it's not even a question of whether he did it right,
but it's a matter of whether or not it's legal.
The camp you had to campaign finance violation.
If the lawyer,
yeah,
that's a campaign finance pen.
Then meeting to knowing about the payout is like obstruct admitting to
obstruction.
It's like a whole lot there.
When he talked about it in that interview,
when someone caught him getting onto his plane and he acknowledged the the
lawsuits,
whoops,
just he fucks up,
man.
He doesn't know how to shut the fuck up and not only that,
his whole life has been about not shutting the fuck up about saying whatever you
want.
Like that's his instincts and all sudden you put them in this position like you
saw an ability.
What's that?
I want you to be a totally different thing.
Now I want you to be presidential.
Yeah.
You've always trying to pick fights with Joe Biden on Twitter.
You're not going to change a 70 year old billionaire.
You're not going to change that guy.
He's been told yes a thousand times a day for last 40 years.
Do you think's going to happen with him?
Do you think they're going to kick him out?
Like what do you think's going to happen?
I think it's not going to,
I think it's,
I just don't see how he can make it through for you.
I don't know.
It's the only thing.
One year.
Yeah.
It's been here in a very,
very bad,
it's very bad.